DAVID VAN OSS >> Hi, may name's David Van
Oss from PRTN Management Consultants. I'm
here in Davos. In regards to whether or not
the economy or the environment will win out
in 2009, I think the answer is that probably
it will. But if economic metrics fully captured
the cost of the environment, then you would
see some of the contradictions that we face
disappear.
The other thing that's absolutely critical
in driving that discussion forward is the
extent to which governments prepare to intervene
in the enterprise. When you look-if you look
at things like blogging, if you look at things
like the exploitation of water resources,
if you looked at-ah-countless other environmental
issues, you'd find that-ah-the roll of governments
in producing transferable and tradable-ah-economically
rational outcomes is critical. Ah-if we can
get that right, then some of these contradictions
are going to disappear.